So, that's very good. So, you, were able to realize that Pavlov is
in Nash equilibrium. But we can go further than that. Or farther, than that.
>> Further.
>> We can go further than that. And show that in fact Pavlov is sub-game
perfect. So, unlike tit for tat. It's
actually subgame perfect. So let's let's take a
look at how we could convince ourselves of that. So I think the important thing
to see is that by feeding these two
Pavlov machines different sequences we can get into
any of these four different combinations of states.
They're both in the cooperation state. They're both
in the. Both in the defect state, ones
cooperate, ones defect, ones defect and ones cooperate.
>> Mh-hm.
>> so is it the case, that no matter which state
that those are in, that the average reward is going to be
mutual cooperation. So let's check, if they are both cooperating, and we
continue with these Pavlov machines then they will mutually cooperate, so yes.
>> Mh-hm.
Alright if they're in defect defect then what's going to happen?
>> Well then they both agree, so then they cooperate.
>> So they're going to move to cooperate
and then they'll stay there forever, so
then that'll be mutual cooperation. Awesome. What
if ones in cooperation and ones in defect?
>> Then they disagree.
>> Right. And they move to the other state.
>> More specifically what?
>> Oh, I don't know [LAUGH], I can't remember. I'm trying to keep
track of who, who's who. So if I cooperate. and you defect, then let's
see the guy who cooperates moves to defect. And the guy who defects
moves to defect. Because you, and now
you agree, and so you're going to cooperate.
>> Boom. So, when we're in the
cooperate defect state, then on the first move.
Let's see, you just, yeah, the right-hand
Pavlov just defected, so that causes this transition.
And this guy just cooperated, which causes this
transition, so that we've gone to defect defect.
>> Right. Which means that
we're going to average cooperation, because [CROSSTALK]
>> Mm-hm.
>> That's where we're going to get stuck in the long run.
>> Right.
>> And the same thing works through here. Boom.
>> That's actually very cool, and kind of counter-intuitive.
>> Yeah. And truly neat. So sort of no matter what
weird sequence we've been fed we manage to
resynchronize and then return to a mutually cooperative state.
>> So I have a question for you.
>> Go for it. So presumably this is really cool
like mathmatically because now we shold all do, we should
all be Pavlovians. Like we're all Kinseans. ANd then we
just kind of move forward from there. D people do this?
>> I don't know the answer to that question.
>> I mean other than men on a basketball course.
>> Sure, you can always return to that. Though I'm not sure I'm aware of any
analyses of men on a basketball court and
whether or not You know, people have analyzed that.
>> Hmm.
>> But how about this. If I find
out, I will post something on the instructor's comments.
>> Okay, that sounds reasonable. So Pavlov
is subgame perfect. That's awesome. So remind
me again why I care that something is subgame perfect? Because it means that,
so let's say that you actually, so I'm being this left Pavlov
and you defect and me and you're like yeah I'm going to
defect on you because I just want to take advantage of you,
and you're, you're going to forgive me and I will have gotten this
extra bonus for that. And what it turns out is that No,
if we do Pavlov versus Pavlov, we're going to fall into mutual cooperation
no matter what. So, so, so this defection that I do, this,
this threat, this punishment that I deal out to you, you can earn
it back, and we can go back into a cooperative state.
>> Right.
>> So, it's worth it to me to punish
you, because I know that it's not going to cost
me anything in the long run, and it stabilizes your
behavior in the short run. Sure. It makes perfect sense.
>> So it becomes a plausible threat.
>> I like it.